Democrats took to the Senate floor last
night to call out Republicans for
crafting their health care bill behind
closed doors a CBS News poll just out
this morning shows a large majority of
Americans 73% say Senate Republicans
should discuss their health care plan in
public in the open 57% of Americans say
Obamacare needs some changes
28% want it repealed entirely Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
latest on this story it's a good morning
good morning at Senate Republicans are
now signaling that they could release
the text of this major piece of
legislation by the end of the week and
that would give the full Senate just a
week to review it because Senate
Republican leaders want to hold a vote
before the July 4th recess now that is
an ambitious deadline for Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell who is
one of the members of this 13 person
working group that has been drafting the
new law behind closed doors Democrats as
you mentioned took to the Senate floor
all afternoon and evening to criticize
the secretive process these 13 senators
represent just 10 states out of our 50
we're talking about 1/6 to 1/5 of the
American economy what are you afraid of
bring that bill out what's going on here
I won't vote for anything that's being
jammed down America's throats now this
rush to move forward is a risky one
because many Republican senators don't
even know yet what is in the bill and
there is a very narrow margin here 50 of
the 52 Republican senators need to be on
board and vote YES to pass the bill the
challenge for Senate Republicans is that
they need to try to come up with
something that pushes fewer people off
of the insurance rolls then the House
GOP bill appears to do and you'll recall
Charlie that the president celebrated
when that House bill passed but then
later called it mean
I do indeed Nancy thanks